wenn man die gemeinsame sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik der eu analysiert
stellt sich die frage was hat sich
geändert
gibt es neue herausforderungen gibt es
neue risiken und gefahren auf die sich
die un stellen betrachtet man die
aktuellen sicherheitspolitischen
rahmenbedingungen so stecken vor allem
drei bereiche ins auge
das erste ein enormer globaler
sicherheitspolitischer wettbewerb wir
haben hier die hauptakteure usa china
russland und auch europa und nur ein
indikator für diese entwicklung sind die
verteidigungsausgaben die mit ausnahme
europas in allen bereichen steigen und
europa noch das manko hat der
ineffizienz der zweite bereich ist das
verhältnis zwischen europa und den usa
und großbritannien
diese transatlantische achse ist nicht
mehr so fest wie sie bisher waren wir
wissen nicht ob der schutzschirm der usa
über europa nicht schon löcher hat der
dritte bereich ist der krisen bogen der
europa umgibt vom nordosten bis in den
süden also von der ukraine vom baltikum
über den nahen osten über libyen dies
nach mali wo er unglaublich viele
auswirkungen richtung europa sich
ergeben und europa entsprechende
maßnahmen ergreifen muss
was macht und plant die eu angesichts
dieser veränderungen und
herausforderungen im vorigen video habe
ich schon die vielen einsätze und
missionen angesprochen für die soll ein
gemeinsames kommando geschaffen werden
insgesamt geht es aber um eine
strategische autonomie wie das
bezeichnet wird es geht darum dass
europa unabhängig von anderen aber
gemeinsam mit ihnen agieren und handeln
können soll
ein gutes beispiel ist der satellit
galileo der es ermöglicht hier
unabhängig von anderen geodaten für
europa zu haben und sicher zu stellen
also unabhängig zu sein
ein zweiter bereich ist der von energie
und ressourcen wo auch europa für sich
schauen muss was ist der bedarf und wo
kann ich diesen bedarf decken im bereich
des militärischen geht es darum eine
gemeinsame verteidigungs forschung und
entwicklung zu etablieren
man will letztlich zu einer gemeinsamen
beschaffungspolitik kommen und die krone
wäre des ganzen jene gemeinsame
europäische militärplanungen
streitkräfte planung und ausrichtung zu
haben aber das ist nur ferne
zukunftsmusik
ein wichtiger hinweis in diesem
zusammenhang ist die existenz der nato
viele meinen dass es hier eine rivalität
gebe die sehe ich in der form nicht es
geht eigentlich darum hier europäische
kapazitäten zu entwickeln und es ist
völlig nachgeordnet ob das im rahmen der
nato oder im rahmen der eu erfolgt die
eu sieht sich im sicherheitspolitischen
bereich mit vielfältigen
herausforderungen konfrontiert man
könnte sagen europäische
herausforderungen die europäische
lösungen erfordern
mit der gemeinsamen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik gibt es den
rechtlichen und politischen rahmen um
hier geschlossen und gemeinsam zu
agieren
die größte herausforderung besteht wohl
darin dass hier der wille zur
zusammenarbeit innerhalb der eu
gefestigt und ausgebaut wird und hier
nationale vorbehalte überwunden werden
ich habe schon angesprochen eine
gemeinsame beschaffung sparte einfach
viel geld geht es vw könnte daher
bedeuten effektiver effizienter und ein
besseres image und eine höhere bedeutung
für die eu im globalen wettbewerb über
die weitere entwicklung der gsv wird
nicht der praxis also das wegbrechen
großbritanniens entscheiden sondern der
wille zur zusammenarbeit der 27
eu-mitglieder damit zurück zur
ausgangsfrage wann kommt nun eine eu
armee das wird noch dauern aber eine eu
armee wäre der logische enke einer
systematischen entwicklung der
gemeinsamen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik
hier noch ein kleiner zusatz die
national armeen werden deswegen nicht
verschwinden denn jeder staat hat
spezifische aufgaben wie zum beispiel
österreich mit der katastrophenhilfe für
seine armee zu hause
ich gehe daher von einem
zwei-säulen-modell aus einmal die
nationale komponente und einmal für
internationale einsätze
[Musik]